later today a time of recording BBC will
be releasing power of the doctor the
final appearance of Jody Whitaker as the
13th Doctor I'll have my review up as
soon as I can on that but at the front
end of it you are going to see this this
is a notice I've been putting in front
of all BBC owned properties for a while
now largely in response to an article
that appeared on the BBC News website a
little over a year ago now some might be
wondering since that article was a year
ago why am I still putting it there and
that's why I'm making this short to put
it briefly while there has not been
anything as egregious as that article in
terms of open transphobia and hostility
towards trans women in particular the
BBC does continue to exhibit various
forms of transphobia such as dead naming
Elon musk's daughter in an article that
had nothing to do with the fact that she
was trans so you will continue to see
that now and into the foreseeable future
I'm gonna keep it as long as it's
relevant and it remains so